Thank you.
Uddhanku Jai Bhi Dhammanku Jai Bhi Sangam Pu Jai Bhi
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samasambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samasambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samasambuddhasa
Udang Saranang Gacami Dhamang Saranang Gacami Sanggang Saranang Gacami Duthi Ampi Udang Saranang Gacami
Duthi Ampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami Duthi Ampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Thati Ampi Budham Saranam Gacchami Thati Ampi Dhammam Saranam Gacchami
Kati Ampi Sangam Saranam Gacchami Anati Pata Veramani Sikapadam Samadhyami Adi Nagana Veramani Sikapadam Samadhyami
Kame sumi cacara veramani sikapadam samadhi amin.
Musa wada veramani sikapadam samadhi amin.
Surah Meriah Majjhapamadathana
Vairamani Sikapadam Samadhi Amin.
Vida me silam agapalanyanasa pachayohotu.
Iti piso bhagavah arahamsammasambuddho vijjacharanasampanno sugato lokavidhu anuttaro purisadhammasarati satta-deva-manusanamputtobhagavati
ye ca buddha-aditha ca ye ca buddha-anagadha pachupanna ca ye buddha-aham vandami-sabhadha nati me saranam anyam buddho me saranam varam etena sacca vajena hotu me jaya-mangalam
Kāye na vāca-cittay na pā-māde na māyā-kathāṃ Ācchayāṃ kāma-mibhante bhūrī-paññā tathā-gathā Svakāto bhagavata-dhammo sāndhitiko akaliko
Ehi Pasiko Opanayiko Pachatam Veditabo Vinyuhiti Yechadama Atitacha Yechadama Anagatha Pachupanachaya Dhamma Aham Vandami Sabadam
nāti me sāraṇaṁ anyāṁ tamo me sāraṇaṁ varāṁ ete na sācchā vācchē na hūtu me jāya-maṅgalāṁ kāye na vācchā cittē na pāma de na māyā kathāṁ acchā yāṅ kāma me dhammā sāndhitika akalika
Supatipanno bhagavato savakasangho Pujupatipanno bhagavato savakasangho Nyayapatipanno bhagavato savakasangho
Samicchipatipanno bhagavato savakasangho Yadidhanjatari purisayugani attapurisapukala
Hei sa bhagavato sa vakasangho Pahuneyo pahuneyo Dakineyo anjali karaneyo Anuttaran punaketam lukasati Ye ca sangha adhita ca Ye ca sangha anagata
Pachupanna Chayi Sangha Aham Vandami Sabadam Gnatime Saranam Ganyam Sangome Saranam Varam Etena Satya Vachena Hotume Jaya Mangalam Kayena Vachachitena Pamatena Mayakatam
Acheyankamamesangapunyaketamanuptaran Anekajatisansaransandawisanmanibisan Gahakerakamgawesantudukajatipunapunam
Gahakarakadithauzipunagehanakahazi Sabatebhasukabagakahakuthamvisankatam Visankarakatanchitamthananamkayamachakam
Awija Pacha Sankara Sankara Pacha Vinyana Vinyana Pacha Nama Rupa Nama Rupa Pacha Salayatana Salayatana Pacha Paso Pasa Pacha Vedana Vedana Pacha Tangha Tangha Pacha Upadana
Upadana Pachabhava Upavapachajati Jati Pachaya Jara Maranan Soka Parideva Dukkha Domina Supaya Sasambhavanti Deva Mitasa Kevalasa Dukkha Kandasa Samudaya Hoti
avijjaya tveva asesa viraga niroda sankara nirodo sankara niroda vijnana nirodo vijnana niroda nama rupa nirodo nama rupa niroda salayatna nirodo
salayatana niroda, pasa nirodo pasa niroda, vedana nirodo vedana niroda, tanda nirodo tanda niroda, upadana nirodo upadana niroda, bhava nirodo
Bhava Nirodha Jati Nirodo Jati Nirodha Jara Maranam Soka Hari Deva Dukha Domina Supayasa Nirojanti Ewa Vittasa Kevalasa Dukha Kandasa Nirodo Hoti
Sabe sankarani jati yadapanya yapasati Adhani bindati duke esamago vissudhya Sabe sankarani jati yadapanya yapasati Adhani bindati duke esamago vissudhya
Sabbe dhamma anattati adhapanya yappasati Atthani bhindati duke esamago vissudhiyam Anicca vattasankara upadhavaya dhammino Upajitvanirujanti tesang upasamosukho
Dukkha Vata Sankara Upadavaya Damino Upajitva Nirujanti Tesam Upasamo Sukho Anatta Vata Sankara Upadavaya Damino Upajitva Nirujanti Tesam Upasamo Sukho
So we can bring to mind anyone we know is having a hard time.
And at this moment, there are people who are suffering from a physical or mental disease.
There are people in the process of dying and those who have died and left grieving family, relatives and friends.
And there are people going hungry, homeless and destitute.
There are those struggling with personal or interpersonal difficulties.
All the victims of prejudices,
All those caught up in wars and repressive regimes and those being tortured.
All those suffering from natural disasters and climate crisis.
All the sentient beings are being cruelly treated and unnecessarily slaughtered.
and all who find life meaningless.
Karaniyam ratakusalena yantam santam padam abhisame ca sakoju ca suju ca suvajo ca samudu anaptimani santu sakoja subharu ca
Apakichocha salahu kauti Santindriyocha nipakocha Apagabokule suvananukido Nacchakudamsamachare kenshi Yena vinyupare upavadeyom Sukhino vakemino hontu
Sābe sātā bāvantu sukhi tathā Ye kecchī pāna-bhūtati Tāsa vāta-vāra-vāāna-vāseṣa Dīgāvā ye vāntava Majjhima-rasa-kanukatulā
Dītāvā yevā adhītā yecchādure vāsānti āvidhūre Bhūtāvā sambhāveṣīvā sābe satāvā vāntu sukhi tathā Nāparo parambhikubheta nātimanyetā kathā cīnā kīcchī
Byalosana bhakti-kasanya, Nanyamanya sadhukam itchaya.
Mata yata niyamputta, Ayusahekamputtambanurake.
Pevampi sababutesu, Manasambhavaye aparimana.
Netencha Sabalokasmi Manasambhavaye Aparimanam Udamadocha Thiriyamcha Asambhadam Maweram Asambhadam Thitancharam Nisinova Sayanova Yavatasa Vigatamido
etam satimna dhiteya brahma-metam viharam itamadhu dhiting ca anupagamah silavah dasanena sampanam kameh suvinayakedham nahijatukabhasayam punaretiti
Our resolutions for the day, something we want to do, something we don't want to do.
Ima ya dhamma lu dhamma pati pati ya buddham puje mi Ima ya dhamma lu dhamma pati pati ya buddham puje mi
Himayadham anudam apati-patiya Sangam pujebi